[Musique]
c'est le grand soir
soit pas nerveux devrait pas quelque
procès fait pas tout foiré je t'aime moi
aussi je t'aime on va faire une fausse
au vaisseau merdique aller grand sourire
et le monde jeunes et ça vous dit
mélissa salué philippe ouah ça fait un
sacré bout de temps ça doit vous sembler
assez étrange que je débarque comme ça
après toutes ces années
je n'a été qu'un accroc ni
la nuit où il est mort il ya cinq ans
une sorte d'étrange miracle s'est
produit ce bébé qui bouge en moi et
l'enfant de ronnie foule a immédiatement
d'heure mais ce qu'elle raconte est
absolument impossible
c'est pas absolument impossible
ouais parce qu'elle avait l'air bien
pourquoi tu fais ça
[Musique]
on aurait aimé que tu veilles sur elle
vous avez toujours bien truc
c'est beaucoup plus vaste que tout ce
que vous voyez au santé
je ne suis pas folle à lier c'est
vraiment la seule et unique réponse ah
ouais
ça me perturbe
qu'est ce que tu lui as fait richard
tu devais tellement fière de toi et de
ta petite supercherie mais quelle
horreur
si nous connaissions la vérité ce serait
moins effrayant au plus encore